[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen rallye fällt
heute gehts regenbogen macarons und
diese werde ich mit sieben verschiedenen
füllungen zu bereiten
aber jetzt keine angst die füllungen
sind super einfach ich mache eine basis
gräbt das ist die französische
buttercreme und dann variiere ich sie
auf sieben verschiedene arten die
markierung schaden habe ich bereits
gebacken
da könnte in meinem grundrezept
nachschauen das werde ich auch super
einfach ihr könnt die tipps beachten und
dann gingen sie euch auf jeden fall auch
bei den farben habe ich mir ausgesucht
rot rosa orange gelb grün blau und lila
bevor ich jetzt aber die französische
buttercreme zubereite bereit ich erstmal
die zutaten vor ich mache nämlich eine
creme und nehmen dann einfach zutaten um
sie abzuwandeln und die müsst ihr vorher
eben ein kochen oder ihr nehmt einfach
marmelade
ich nehme hier frische früchte bzw
gefrorene früchte und startete mit der
himberger caro creme und zwar nehme ich
jetzt hier gefrorene himbeeren füllen
sie in einen topf und lasse jetzt so
lange ein kochen bis die flüssigkeit
fast verdunstet dann habt ihr am ende
hier diese konsistenz und damit die
kerne noch verschwinden passiere ich sie
einfach durch ein haarsieb und hab dann
himbeer moos
für die dealer macarons koch ist blau
werden ein und für die roten hacker aus
grieskirchen 1
[Musik]
für die orangen macarons nehme ich jetzt
eine mango und maracuja hätte jetzt hier
einmal schälen und pürieren
dann haben die den tollen geschmack
[Musik]
bevor die maracuja dazu kommt ist aber
die mango ernst
und dann die maracuja einfach halbieren
und das innere herauslaufen
[Musik]
und das maracuja mango für ihr werdet
auch eingekocht bis keine flüssigkeit
mehr da ist
[Musik]
und für die zitronen macarons nehme ich
jetzt zitronen bei denen man die schale
verzehren kann die stele ich jetzt hier
ab nur den gelben teil nicht das weiß
dann kommt die schale hier direkt in
einen topf 1 und kann mit dem
zitronensaft zusammen aufkochen und ein
bisschen einkochen damit einfach
dickflüssiger wird
[Musik]
wir kommen jetzt gerade noch ein
bisschen zucker rein damit es nicht zu
sauer wird und dann schön dickflüssig
eingehalten
[Musik]
und für die grünen macarons mache ich
jetzt eine hugo variante das heißt minze
und limette und da nehme ich jetzt
einfach eine reibe ihr könnt aber auch
hier gerne die elemente schale einfach
wieder abstellen
[Musik]
und dann einfach auch mit zucker
größeren einkochen lassen bis es schön
dick flüssig ist
[Musik]
falls euch das hier zu aufwendig ist
dann könnt ihr wirklich auf marmelade
zurückgreifen und bei limette nur ein
bisschen limetten abrieb so buttercreme
dazugeben und auch so bei der zitrone
so ist es wirklich etwas aufwendiger
arbeit aber natürlich sehr lecker und so
werden sie auch nicht sooo süß weil ich
einfach nicht so viel extra zucker dabei
habe ich hab ich jetzt also die
füllungen
hier habe ich heidelbeeren tonkabohne
für die blauen
hugo zitrone mango maracuja kirsche und
himbeere und jetzt zeige ich euch noch
die zutaten für die buttercreme und da
mache ich jetzt eine eigelb
resteverwertung weil ich ja bei den
makro nur das eiweiß benutzer bietet
jetzt die butter kleben etwas angepasst
iker ich habe jetzt hier 150 gramm
eigelb eine prise salz 100 gramm zucker
und 250 gramm butter
wichtig ist dass die zutaten einfach
jetzt alle zimmer warm sind und damit
das eigelb jetzt nicht roh in die
buttercreme kommt wird erhitzt hier über
einem wasserbad gemeinsam mit dem zucker
wird sozusagen pasteurisiert also die
eigelbe hier in die schüsse ihr könnt
auch gerne eine amerikanische
buttercreme machen dass es dann einfach
nur butter und puderzucker ist auch ganz
lecker in verbindung mit den fruchtmus
oder mit dem fluggerät aber muss ich
sagen dass ich mir immer ein bisschen zu
heavy also nehme ich doch lieber die
eigelb variante sind jetzt hier schön
verrühren
und für etwa zehn minuten lang über dem
wasserbad erhitzen
so werden dann wirklich auch alle keime
abgetötet und in der zwischenzeit kann
ich dann schon mal die weiche butter
richtig schön luftig und cremig
aufschlagen lassen
jetzt ist war es einfach zum kochen
bringen und stand
und immer höheren damit kein rührei
entsteht
[Musik]
ihr seht schon richtig das volumen hat
sich verdreifacht
richtig schön cremig und das war jetzt
zehn minuten einfach auf dem wasserbad
jetzt muss ich natürlich die eigene
masse wieder herunter kühlen sonst wird
er die butter auf jeden fall sofort
schmelzen
also wechsle ich jetzt hier einfach kurz
die schüsseln aus die butter ist auch
richtig schön weiß cremig mich kribbeln
in den fingern ich würde es am liebsten
einfach wandel extrakt dazu geben und
richtig leckere vanille buttercreme
machen aber ich habe heute sieben
geschmacksrichtungen also halte ich mich
zurück
jetzt geht der fachausschüsse rein den
schneebesen drauf und kühl ist die creme
herunter durch das rühren und es dauert
so etwa zehn minuten
also sollte da nicht wärmer als anfang
sein und dann kann ich es mit der butter
vermischen
jetzt ist die eier zucker creme schön
abgekühlt jetzt hier einmal die schüsse
verhallt jetzt auch den schneebesen
weiterhin damit die creme schön luftig
wird und die butter ist ja auch jetzt
wirklich richtig richtig weich und jetzt
kommt hier einfach esslöffel weise die
eier zucker creme unter die buttercreme
[Musik]
die buttercreme ist bereit und jetzt
teil ich sehe auf 7 schälchen auf und
verrät dann einfach mit den ganzen
fruchtpüree es natürlich einzeln und
separat jetzt gebe ich einfach immer ein
bisschen fruchtpüree dazu und riss unter
die buttercreme und falls benötigt könnt
ihr hier noch farbe zufügen wenn ihr
möchtet
[Musik]
die blauen macarons verfeinere ich jetzt
mit tonkabohne das ist ein richtig
leckeres gewürz kommt bei mir gleich auf
mit vanille und für mich riecht
tonkabohne bist du nach waldmeister und
vanille für die samira rechts nach
maxipark also nach man für den josch
rechts nach anis ich finde es riecht
einfach lecker jetzt einfach dazu
gerieben nicht so viel
kein kampf da kommt ein bisschen blau
war aber noch dazu
[Musik]
ich glaube ich hier werde ich jetzt
keine farbe brauchen bei glaube
[Musik]
die cremes habe ich jetzt alle in
spritzbeutel gefüllt da braucht es keine
tolle dazu und jetzt werden sie gefüllt
schön mittig nicht so viel und dann
zusammengesetzt jemand so einen kleinen
klecks in der mitte dann kommt der
deckel drauf und am rand muss man so ein
bisschen die füllung noch sehen
[Musik]
ich bin echt fix und fertig es war jetzt
echt eine riesengroße makarov produktion
die siebenfache menge in allen farben
aber ich glaube ich konnte euch ziemlich
cool zeigen wie ihr sieben verschiedene
füllungen machen könnt und wirklich
dabei nur ein basis rezept habt und zur
rainbow macarons muss man schon sagen
die sind echt wert die darf ich jetzt
allerdings noch nicht probieren denn
ganz frisch gefüllten macarons einfach
noch zu fest das heißt die kommen jetzt
eingepackt über nacht noch mal in den
kühlschrank
entweder einen tag oder zwei tage und
dann können wir erst probieren
[Musik]
wow perfekt genauso wenn es nämlich
einfach die garching boards von mir
genommen und paar habt ihr jetzt noch
klein geschnitten und dann einfach mit
holz dort zwischen auf ein kuchenteller
und da mache ich jetzt eine regenbogen
einen regenbogen makarov turm ja das was
sie draußen gerade probiert haben
macarons wollt ihr noch ein probieren
der kleine machst du einen mit
heidelbeeren du auch privat kommt
blau ist tonkabohne nachdem ich gestern
gemacht die mussten eine nacht
durchziehen geschmeckt schmeckte der
tonkabohne raus das aroma für jeden
schmeckt tonkabohne anders also ich
finde schmeckbar noch weltmeister im
irak sagt er marzipan los sagt anis des
spuckens kongo und perfekt ich hoffe
dass der regenbogen turm gut ankommt
denn diese torte diese markierung torte
diesen turm bekommt später der wie nie
zu seinem geburtstag unser freund wenig
ja da bringe ich das dann ich glaube
dass ich einfach mal ein schönes anderes
geschenk oder perfekt dann brauche ich
jetzt noch den turm zusammen dann dürft
ihr gerne alles was ich nicht für den
turm brauche bringe ich natürlich zu
euch an die zwei etagen bauer
danke doch jetzt ganz klar zähne
[Musik]
aber ich glaube ich ganz gut aus ich
habe es noch ein problem der transport
nach heidelberg
aber ich habe das jetzt mit schokolade
daran geklebt und stellte jetzt erstmal
im kühlschrank und dann glaube ich nehme
ich einfach frischhaltefolie außenrum
damit die macarons im auto nicht
herunterfallen und nehmen eine
transportbox als so eine styropor box
und dann dürfte es eigentlich
funktionieren also falls sie aus euren
regenbogen macarons auch einen turm
bauen wollt dann könnt ihr das gerne
machen das rezept für die regenbogen
macarons und die sieben einzelnen
füllungen die gibt es - blog.de ich
wünsche euch viel spaß beim nachmachen
und schreibt mir gerne falls ihr euch
noch weitere macarons wünscht aber
entschuldigt auch wenn ich jetzt erstmal
zwei wochen keine macke auspacken werde
es bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]
das modell her gesehen ja stimmt nicht
auch die völlig falsch sich jetzt vom
starken fuß steckten
das heißt künftig nur noch boden lassen
aus ich schon hoch aber nicht zu hoch
ja